i woke up this morning came down here
and i was listening to jd
talk about this wacky thing he does that
i couldn't even understand
he he's in a pool he put pays 89
to try to win baseball cards it's weird
how do you win
and what is the purpose of it jd will
explain to you
what he does for 89 and then i'm going
to listen to you and ask the same exact
questions that i asked them this morning
and you're still not going to understand
so there are these expensive cards and
what people do
is they sign up for slots uh
to get uh uh to go into this pack
opening okay so what you do is you pay
say with this certain thing i did i paid
89
for a slot into this pack opening i got
assigned a team at random
like i got assigned to houston astros
so what happens is these people open the
boxes of cards
and say a houston astros card comes up
they would send me that card that's
that's basically it
oh my god you have no idea what he said
right
that's yeah no i don't first of all
who puts these cards in a pack
so okay i went through let me tell you
what i know
okay first of all i was like for 10
minutes i said like
jd you're collecting baseball cards that
took me 10 minutes to even understand
why
he goes these are really expensive
baseball cards
what's expensive about them well some of
the cars are autographed
and or have pieces of uniform or
uh like a cleat or something the uh
equipment that they use during the game
so complete yeah yeah there's a cleat in
there with the cart
so evidently i said to jd why not just
take eighty nine dollars and buy a bunch
of baseball cards and and see
but he's like saying it cost fifteen
hundred dollars to get a pack of these
cards
he was assigned a team and his team he
got one card but was worth like eight
dollars and he paid 89
right but it's like gambling it's like
you you take a a a spin of the dice you
know what i mean and see if you get
where's this baseball card i haven't
gotten that yet
the auction happened on tuesday so i'm
waiting to have that
shift to me